once we get past all the technical stuff
then it's just uh just chest time eric
um yeah so for everyone who's never seen
me before
i'm eric gachenko as it says
i may try this i don't know how when my
camera angle is working right now but it
says it right below my name
uh i am a chess expert i'm not titled or
anything
but uh i'm pretty pretty decent at this
game
silent t it's pronounced um if you want
to be a technical about it it's
pronounced
cachianko uh i'm not even sure if i'm
pronouncing my own name correctly but
if you would like to try that's how it
goes i think what we're gonna do
first is do
puzzle eraser it's a new it's a new
thing
i'm gonna change the title right now
i think i need to create a new really
big decision
i need to create a new scene um
i'm gonna just play this game out eric
this is grandma and grandpa checking in
just wanted to say how proud of
this out of you we are young man keep it
up
bishop to d3 was played cd4 what's your
name grandma
and or grandpa again knight to b3
i didn't know you knew what switch was
e7 and now look at this one
g3 felt like yeah he's gonna have all
the bullets in his gun and guess who's
gonna be looking on the back uh
oh so many hearts my uncle's here too
how did you guys find my stream a5 and
uh quincy two landed on the board that's
so cool i've always wanted my uh
my uncle to watch my myself uh or watch
me play chess
good energy yes of course of course as
always
as always in this five minutes that i've
been streaming so far
always keep good energy are you
listening to maurice ashley oh
yeah um i'm playing a uh
google extension right now which like
commentates all my games
all over the position um actually no
sorry sorry he's we um we hired him
as a commentator for my bullet games
i'm also going to relocate where i have
to look for twitch chat because
i have to like i have to do a big head
movement that's wasting a lot of time
you would never put your rook on f8 and
think that's where you belong
h2 excuse you
think i'm i'm usually good at talking
and uh and playing but
the whole head thing is messing me up
for sure right now doesn't really do
anything
uh i i think i should beat this guy
though he's pretty slow extremely
exciting came out the gate
really fast
okay we're just going to push my pawn
and put my knight there bring my rook
around
go to like f6 maybe by the way bishop
takes e5 looks like it was a
serious yeah okay let me just take
everything maybe even this
queen to g3 with check oh i didn't see
that he could block but okay
he can he can play like every move right
now but i'm just going to flag him
this spectacular move um
expert erika chanko that's me that
google extension is cracking me up
yeah it cracked me up as well the first
time i used it and i have a shout out
i'm your producer binomial
uh shout out to my producer binomial
that was just
novelties that would just be coming out
of nowhere by the way and
i just googled your name and your
linkedin picture is not very
professional
frank uncle frank what
no uncle frank come on my picture's very
professional
uh knight c3 now maybe you can play d4
and
move nice completely forgot about that
extension i don't know this
he's in the back right now i can go get
him if you need me to
come up a piece so hopefully he is on
second castle
oh he threatened my guy and then i
forgot analysis with your own personal
assessment of the situation
um okay whatever uh yeah after this game
i'm gonna
move my my chat somewhere so i can uh
play without looking over there i said i
was gonna do that last game but i forgot
uh you're going to lose he's like
attacking me with his pawns but i don't
know
like where that's going now
i take with like this guy and then i go
on the h file
i just trade everything and then i'm
just in a better end game or something
yeah you know what
95
i'm not really sure when i where my
night's going but i'm gaining time so
you know can never be bad let's gain
time
oh however rookie stop attacking me rook
to f1
why did i all attack his pawn with this
i'll never see it coming
okay that's a free pawn so
am i checking or something what are you
gonna do about that
i think the the goal is gonna get to be
to get to
2400 bullet on this account i think the
current peak of this account is
something like
2100 and i should be able to easily um
another check e7 suddenly rook to g3
actually the move i hung my pawn but it
doesn't matter
all right um i'm gonna hide the board
for a second here to put the uh
the chat over here i think i'll just
start with bullet actually
hey eric it's your eighth cousin's dogs
cats fish here oh wait i forgot i
put it over here hey eric it's your
eighth cousins dogs cats fish here keep
up the good work
the only beautiful one here is you eric
much love from grandpa
grandma and grandpa i'm feeling so loved
right now i don't
i mean my entire family is here
my pets are here my pets families are
here it's crazy
i mean this is this okay i'm gonna
change my title one more time
feels good man title
pushing for 2400
bullets so now the move
i don't want you in my position at all
that is my cat in case um i guess you
guys are unaware
it's fine you can i'm sure he would
enjoy the intention so
i think he probably will make an
appearance at some point to be honest
because
it's very rare that he won't try to
start um
scratching on my door after about like
10 minutes of not being look at this and
now queen went to c7
10 minutes of not bothering me bishop to
b6 queen b8
really showed us a sparkling game okay i
mean this
this looks really bad i guess you can
just like trade everything
but after knight takes e5 this is good
for me yeah bring it but now
and now the move knight takes g4 wow
old i should have gone this way about
but okay this is this is really good i
guess he's gonna go there
so i should stop that or something the
only thing is in this case
queen h5 right g6 queen eight
i'd actually have to think for a second
here crawling all over this this move is
good
it's pretty good
i wish i went this way so i could put my
rook in h1
black on the board i'll threaten this
i don't know how he stops because if he
goes there i just attack his pawn
on e7 rook e1
that's kind of bad
it's probably many good moves right
who knows which one's the best one let's
just do that i need to stop thinking
this much
okay this one's mate so this bishop has
this of course
i'm gonna flag so that's a problem i
don't have all the analysis i think my
position
i don't know if i had more if i was like
about to fly him then i'd be okay here
but
i played way too slowly oh he played
that
thought he played this line with the
engines check king g1
i don't even think i'm fast enough to
win this game 88
was played this this see if i can trick
him all right
and then gh5 queen takes on h5 and
dude i'll catch you the move g6 appeared
on the board uh
queen e6 queen e6
have you ever thought about doing asmr
oh i was actually not that far from
flagging him here
also uh never thought about doing asmr
why do i have a nice voice or something
some people have told me i have a nice
voice but i really heard it
c5 good defense yeah i played pretty
badly i'm
still getting used to the whole like
reading chat thing can you think about
it
i mean if you want to support me in my
asmr asmr
journey then oh yeah i just plundered
this bishop
three bishop on e7 okay
yeah if you want to support me my asmr
journey if you will fund me
then i consider it yeah it's definitely
not a shameful
career at all or anything like that i
think it's really cool
and i say that i'm not sure if i sound
ironic but i'm serious
um this position is not so good it's
really bad
this side of the board is just sold oh
that was a pretty that was a free phone
i didn't even realize that
well now does this work yeah i think it
works
what's going on consider harder please
okay okay if you guys are all
after the move you're all really gonna
if you'll pay to see me do asmr then
i'll do asmr
this is terrible i am playing badly
for anyone who doesn't know unbelievable
me you know i would say i'm about
i'm i'm always you know at least 2400
bullets so this is kind of
just kind of sad don't consider it
please
that's kind of rude who do i trust
i trust sega 99 or everyone else
somewhat boring chess of course and
bishop g5
maybe you can play d4 have you tried
fortnite chess
i don't know what fortnite chess is that
doesn't sound
another move like a good version of
chess
maybe
if you explain it maybe i'll uh i'll try
it
queen g5 check queen d2 queen g6
bishop to d3 was played barely hanging
on by
his fingernails i mean queen d6 queen g5
so not playing so well it's kind of
annoying
i wish i played better chess very very
sneaky uh attempts by
white h6 queen h4
how can you need to like make a move and
uh
after bishop to e6 king to b1
let's just sacrifice upon
you would be surprised how many people
this looks pretty good incredible
b3 a5
queen to g3 and uh so let's keep our
eyes
on i just traded queens that'd be pretty
good probably
okay interesting i think he should still
trade queens but
i just hung a piece or an exchange but
i'll pretend like it was on purpose
it finally came as a surprise to him for
sure
all right have you tried among us i also
don't know what that is
that sounds terrible e7 takes on e7
takes on e7 takes on e7 95
kingy forward man rook to f8
but d2 now actually
c4 and the engine is going crazy so this
is really good for white
yeah is that converting g5 okay it's
pretty slow
um keep your head in the game sport
grandma and grandpa know you can do this
now looking for c5 so are you grandma
and grandpa
like how are you
i think no on d5 analyze it to death
whether or not the idea has merit ed5
rook ac8 b3
so b5
weird defensive wait what are you
what are you saying yes to right now
rookie one
it's okay grandma i i know your english
isn't the best but i still love you
whatever queen d3
a6 well g4 knight to d7
did you watch anime um
it's a freakingly asked question for us
jenner i would say no oh i hung a piece
i gotta stop reading chat i'm so bad at
this
the night already on c5 clearly he sees
something
king g2 all right uh yeah yeah he's
i need to play 30 second chess i know it
sounds crazy because i'm losing one
minute but
uh i needed the opportunity to flag
everyone um
so yeah grandma what are you saying yes
to hello
phil what's up positional bullet chess
is not possible
i don't know if that's oh wow okay no no
no no no i need i need to
change this challenge to like yeah minus
100 maybe
[Music]
um
yeah uh i can play positionally
sometimes
um watch his attack on titan but doesn't
notice attacks on his pieces this is
true
something i'm working on that's noticing
attacks on pieces is difficult
do it so subtly it should make the like
a
the titan noise every single time i
attack my piece
what's up frank
waiting for someone oh i did i did half
plus three that's why no one's accepting
my challenge
okay there we go this guy i don't know i
think i want to farm someone better than
this but i'll
i'll attempt that just to make sure i
can still i chess
can i do the ludwig challenge with subs
no i don't think they'd allow me to do
that bishop dropping
i just tried to castle my queen okay i
it's been a while it's been a while
since i played this game
i think ludwig is making history right
now i think they're going to write about
his current his stream in history books
by the way and bishop let's go
um stop ducking a match against me i
know you're scared
scared of what tactic we all learned
talking about chess
check this out do you remember when i
played you in chess
okay well that guy i gave up
if anyone in the chat is above like 2100
i'll also play them
we got how many viewers we got 37
viewers pretty solid pretty solid
okay we got a 2166 i should be able to
farm this guy pretty
pretty handily
whoa uh i i'm that's about i already
blended upon
i've just never seen queen h4 in this
position so i had to play really fast to
make up for it or something
but expert in front of your name and you
will get more
and even if it is true i don't know if i
want that to be true you suffer as
opposed to just get
destroyed um is that free punch
again 93 could be thought about here
check right bishop takes f3 doesn't do
anything
taking on f3 and black is just suffering
oh
i got to move playing 30 seconds i
should have played rook d4 last night
so in this situation and this line is
just
chaotic to say that just check me
i don't know what i'm doing
knight d5 check this one
and what's amazing about this position
yeah sounds good let's play
i don't have a single challenge on lead
chess right now if you type exclamation
point challenge
or just challenge st louis chess club
unleash us then
i will consider playing you however it's
very unlikely
there's no way any of you are this good
what dpi is that i think i'm on 800 dpi
and
yeah e1 now h5 and bishop g5
knight to d7 this game was not clean
knight d3 i haven't seen it yet
what do you haven't seen what yet now
queen a4
what are you talking about i blunder i
think he has this
yeah but i'll just play fast and win
anyways
rook to d4 trick come on rook a instead
of rookie
a3 yeah it's just a little slow it's a
problem
look at
i've been training to beat you for years
e5 explodes on the board bishop to c4
knight f6 do the jonathan okay doesn't
want to take it 97
that's weird i've never seen this if i
may just throw in this idea the engines
give after takes takes
hi annabella were you thinking about
that
the whole gang is in the chat every
every person i've ever met in in my life
is in the chat
knight to e4 queen over to g6
and black is suffering in this position
my brain just doesn't go this fast
um neither does mine i think bullet
chest is definitely
something that i don't think i don't
really think in bullet just right like
g3 sort of just um
i've played so much of it that
the moves are just happening i guess
that makes any sense
there's very rarely actual calculation
involved in this game
especially in 30 seconds and i think
just having my uh my gamer background
you know allows me to buy people in dumb
positions just because i have decent
mouse movement on c3 knight c6 and
castles rook to e8
bishop to h5 i'm gonna like checkmate
him i should have planned to c7 instead
g3 knight seven bishop on f4 next time
he takes on behavior the engines are
giving those
this is the way chess is meant to be
played exactly
you're not playing chess if you're not
playing bullets
knight d3 uh this is not really good
i have to do this king g2 all right now
you must play rook f8
queen takes d5
rook d8 queen c5 knight takes on d4
takes
on a7 and now king sherwin said seven
alright
takes on e7 takes on e7 i'm just going
to play rook to f8 not very
not playing this very well though i
should still fly again queen c5
king of six queen to c7 e5 and he holds
his sam e5 i like discovered attack
i don't remember where where i did a
discovered attack
but i like them too i like them too when
they work out there's some betters in
vegas
who doesn't e5
bishop i appreciate that queen to e7
and now castles and castles gary
kasparov like preparation
yeah so so far so far i've been doing
well my rating has gone up
the chat is active now the move c4
everyone's happy played c5
engine very intriguing
should have taken it though now it's
just good
what now i look like a genius
i appreciate that i guess okay i don't
look like a genius anymore
that's a free pawn actually the move
took on
d7 i'm gonna lose this game but he's
deciding he could have like
almost made a queen i'll flag him don't
worry
everything's everything's gonna be fine
so bishop to d7 does seem like a solid
move here
bishop everything's fine this guy's slow
i thought i had like five seconds dude
he's a verified streamer
if anyone wants to follow my own twitch
channel uh
which i'm not sure why you would
dude it's shameless of course of course
he's pretty much forced h3
i'm thinking as he sees knight d2 by the
way
and that's a free check that's a free
attack
it's gonna be merciless checks i think
i'm gonna win a piece
or something
and now rogue d1 bishop to e2 here we
have a result it looks like that sky is
starting to get too low rated for me gg
sun
i don't think you guys can see the chat
but he just said gigi's son
is that the main line right it's the
right move i wonder if he's watching
do you know who i am you know i'm a
little child this move
c5 the engine's first choice g5
bishop g3 do you stream chess on your
personal account as well
uh oh my god i just brain farted
um not after that
i don't think i should stream chess
[Music]
work sometime soon just try again
brooke to d6 and it's still high quality
stuff rook to e8
knight that was the blunder oh wait
where was my rook again
oh he flicked with him
all right let's see if he notices that i
promoted a queen
rook g7 take on e4 the king on e6
you know what check except guess what
king f6
take on
i don't like um
okay a lot of things going on in the
chat guess who's finally okay
guess who's finally here okay hi iris my
name is shroud yes
it's me that's streamer should be
interested in joining my new chess
esports team dm a few details c5
yeah sure you can hit me up on twitter
um
you probably are already following me
simply bishop d3 and now the move
d5 but yeah my dms are open i guess if
you're really interested but i would
need a pretty good offer
d4 knight on c6 bishop e7
the move h3 was played knight to e5
now knight takes on uh there's a lot of
spam going on in the chat i'll have to
um
but it just looks complicated it just
just optically just looks
like there's nothing black sorry i think
someone is saying something
that is a question but oh my that is a
long message
it's a very long message
okay this is not going so hot oh i miss
i messed up
i need to play one minute i keep reading
chat but i'm not this good
[Music]
i think this spam is fine not sure if
anyone cares about spam but you know if
the chat's active
just try to like cut if you guys can cut
that coffee pasta in half
just please do that okay i will i'll
i'll time out the next person who does
that spam
but the concept of spamming is not
necessarily false
or not necessarily bad um okay i'm going
to scroll up for a second because i
missed some things
uh eric what's your actual uscf rating
my
rating is uh about 20
30 i think although i haven't played in
a tournament in
a while because of kovid obviously
um i mean this this might be winning
can i get it okay eric is a variety
streamer
blah blah blah i'm ninja uh
very interesting okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna time out this
i'm gonna time you out frank you can't
you can't do that
i just judge you we got to be able to
see the chat all right
um someone had a question where to
practice openings
uh he did the attack that we were
talking about
okay i'm not the one to ask about
openings i'm pretty bad at openings but
what i would do is probably go to um
opening explorer on lead chess and just
put in like
put in the first moves of your opening
and look at the most popular moves
from there and just like you know look
at the tree or whatever
you know what pretty bad answer maybe
but uh
personally i learned openings just from
getting lessons and uh
watching people play chess i watched
people who
played openings that i played and i just
sort of learned through
learned through osmosis um
but if you want to be most efficient and
probably looking yourself at the opening
tree thing is the best
option eric did you get all your friends
to watch
everyone's my friend so everyone who's
watching right now is my friend so yes
this knight moved to c6 put a knight on
e5 knight takes on e5
now knight to d2 knight takes e4 oh see
look
everyone's friends bishop b4 but rook c1
97 a3 i don't know i hung a piece
he didn't take it so everything's fine
okay this guy's this guy's playing
annoyingly fast
at random moments
what a move what a move i'm playing so
bad
[Music]
i thought you played a different move ah
f4 okay i think next a couple games i'm
gonna actually like
play chess instead of reading chat right
looking into chris
i'm not good i'm not cut out for this
for this job
yeah okay i'm gonna i'm just gonna get
to 2200 real quick and then i'll catch
up on the messages because
i'm basically losing half of my clock
for no reason
bishop on g4 bishop d3 has been played
e5
rookie one so c4 first b3 i'll play b3
don't worry
i'll only look at chat when it's not or
when i'm
pretty sure my opponent is going to take
a lot of
knight back to time queens every knight
takes on d4
knight c6 i just hung up i'm gonna stood
this right he saw it i believe he saw it
it was so far across the board how did
he find it bishop to e3
queen e5 bishop d4 queen to e4 never
seen a position like this
it's so chaotic and the move queen c3
what did i just do oh no i missed
clicked why is my bishop there
now it's getting worse and worse this
the move h3 was played genius for f7 to
move
rook to e1
queen g3 okay he's gonna fight cd4
queen b1 is another idea check so
rook to f6 the clock
holy okay no no no no no no no
don't do that please i appreciate the
spam i appreciate
the love you know but it it can happen
[Applause]
bishop to b5 let me get that up
is there a site where i can copy paste
every move for this is silly one second
i'll read that in a moment
that was uh it was ambitious of me to
attempt to read that message
from afar castles
knight to d2 and then nighttime
f6 i'm not going to deal with the g5
idea anymore
knight f3 queen d2 knight a5
okay 50's so we're
g4 broke a4 rook to c2
another check oh b5 was played here came
back to b3 b4
just hang all my pawns until he takes
them on e6
it's always a good strategy and now look
at this one with check
king h3 and king h4 was played i please
accept
kg7 king f6 check king to e7
uh um the question was is there a site
where i can copy paste every move for
the sicilian opening and just train on
it until i have it memorized
um that's pretty
that's pretty grand i don't know i think
you don't understand how
big the sicilian is you can't just
practice you can't just know every line
right
exactly but you can um
you can create a leachate study and put
in all the lines that you will play
i would say that that's pretty useful um
and then if you really just i mean want
to see
every line then you just go on a
database and just look yourself
and that's technically saved for
practice
and then probably uh what's it called
that one website that iris knows
probably
where you um that magnus carlsen's a
part of where you like
you know you make chess moves and stuff
who knows what it's called
josh those um those messages are gonna
get uh
get flagged no no links all right uh
david usa wants to play me but
i'm not gonna play casual rapid right
now i'm sorry
hello goku 10 200 what's up
hey president 17. andrew johnson
that's my favorite president i assume
that's why your name is that
because i have all the residents
memorized
okay iris wants me to do puzzle racer
i'll do it at i'll do it in like 10
minutes
ish hello hello where does this
background sound come from
i have maurice ashley in the studio
right now
just commentating my bullet games
the real answer though is i have this
extension called
it's called dimit dimitt's leeches yeah
dimita leeches
which means dimitri lee chess because
it's dimitri komarov is the
is the main dude but i have it on on uh
marie's mode right now
uh what's his name andrew tang also uses
this extension which is
perhaps where some of you know it from
i'm a big andrew tang fan myself queen
b6
bishop takes on f2 check bishop e3 queen
d3
bishop f5 every single move attack
attack put him on his back foot
this is pure prep attack attack put him
on his back
but still bishop takes jesus does this
work i really wanted that to work
bishop d4 bishop takes on d4 he wants to
trade that's fine
c5 g3 felt like yeah
if i threatened me okay
quieter maurice okay but forgets his
name
king is on the fire yeah i didn't forget
his name
i didn't forget andrew tang's name
how about raided rapid
maybe when i stream some other time i'd
play rapid but today i
definitely just want to play bullets
maybe i'll play blitz later
but definitely right now i'm just in a
bullet mood
and in most of the most times
rapids too close to real chess well
bullets real chess so it's actually not
that close
you gotta play knight a6 take on d5
bishop to b5 of course oh he attacked my
guy seven and what do you do now
has to go there right i sound crazy
he sees something rook b8 uh
this works too fast to follow
take a look um you know i think that
most the people in this chat
not to not to um not to say anyone is
not good at chess but most chess that i
would want to play is probably too hard
for
for some of these people to follow i
missed a free piece
so i think uh uh
i think it's more about the experience
right ex
just enjoy it enjoy the chess you know
on g3 even if you don't understand
i think it's still fun to watch at least
play one minute
but one minute's so slow
um wait a cy
wfx i know who that is okay
it's easier to follow when you're just
watching
hmm i could play bull or i could play
blitz does anyone know how to do a poll
like let's see flash poll that works
fine
i'll do a poll
question bullet or blitz
question mark hold it
blitz duration we'll do a
we'll do a one minute duration because
i'm it's like a bullet
pole
and then how do i check the results of
this okay cool
oh wow four votes for blitz already
i need to see what the blitz rating is
on this account also
2197 okay so i should be able to like
play
blitz
now the engines are not necessarily that
thrilled about this particular move
but the moves they're suggesting i'm i'm
thinking we need to recount on this
i really like white guess what and ten
to two ten to two
only two people have taste
only two
i've let's see absolutely
i've smashed the st louis chess club
account's
peak bullet rating
and then and you want me to stop here
you want me to stop on a
three-game four-game win streak
all right well blitz wins 11 to two
which means i'll do none of the above
and play
actually no i'll probably just i'll do
blitz
i'll do puzzle eraser later i think
david usa bullet
um you're only rated
well not only but you're rated 20 20 uh
2000 so i pretty much i don't really
gain much for playing you
bullet is fun but blitzes to enjoy all
right i will
play blitz under one condition that the
chat
is is cool all right everyone in chat
has to be cool i need
i need to see at least three people type
yes right now
to confirm that you'll be cool because
if i'm playing blitz i'm gonna be
reading
reading uh chat a lot more
eric dodging challenge confirmed
i mean i i could play him but we want to
keep things um
fine i'll play one game with him while
i'm waiting for everyone to say yes
oh we've lost to this dude that wasn't
me don't worry guys i don't think you
can even see that part of the screen but
now looking for one minute now c4 i'm
gonna fall asleep
take on d5 nice e3 look good bishop g7
you're not allowed to say oowoo in this
chat you rule
e3 now castle's knight
takes on d5 no no
all right i should have played there
probably but this is
this looks really strong for me already
uh i think like every move wins
devastating especially this one e6
d4
but it's sharp bishop takes b3
i think i have messed up like i should
have had a cleaner way to win this right
now
the angels are saying kill it kill it
of course i'm still doing fine here
maybe i should have gone there who knows
in this position we thought
he's already commentating like ben
feingold in what way am i accommodating
like ben feingold
tonight d4 for the fans
knight takes on d4 bishop takes on d4
bishop takes b7 rook a7 played instantly
but still agree you even know who ben
feingold is or are you agreeing to
something else
bishop e3 i'm still waiting to know why
how i'm
commentating like ben feingold now look
at this one
you know i'm not playing very well i'm
gonna lose to a two thousand
bishop to f1 unfortunately never mind
this is this should be
winning i'm pretty sure this is
objectively winning but in a bullet game
it's even more objectively winning and
b4
is about to come down to b2 kg5
king g1 yeah no we're not yeah you
played kg4 so king g4 is
rook to g8 i almost just hang oh i
meant to play king of three guys
i hung every single piece in a row at
the end
already getting snarky with chat
what does that mean what am i how am i
being snarky with chat okay so let's see
how many people said yes
we had three people say yes and then one
person say yes so
i'll say like three and a half which is
which is more than i asked for so i will
play blitz
i'm not sure i haven't been trying to be
funny
sorry if i'm sorry if i'm funny
i play this opening every every time i
play chess and then i just
i don't know what to do after like the
first move what i mean
blitz is my worst game on lee chess it's
probably
the same walk us through your moves okay
so i'm going to control the center
and threaten this move here
i have one pawn versus no pawns in the
center of the board
so this game which i believe gives me a
slight advantage in this position
i could castle however i will prevent
bishop g5 first
because he doesn't have any immediate
way to punish me that's the only move
but thus i will follow with
castling on the next move
why do you play this it's so bad i don't
know why i play this it's just because i
don't know what to do okay i think he
should have played there
but he didn't play there and now
i don't really want him to take my
bishop so i have to go there i guess
i'll put my bishop on g4 instead
i dare you to play the french
um
[Music]
and after the move h3 which was played
black
that's my personal channel by the way
anyone is um
interested to follow me uh
yeah i'm not playing the french for any
now the move
knight takes d4
whatever whatever is i will not yeah
simple answer is no
simple answer i think you should play g5
i kind of missed that
bishop to e3
okay he didn't do it i wanna go check
checkmate
but i can't so easily
who asked so this is just actually
fizzling out not sure who that's
directed at
hopefully not me this chat's way too
nice to
say such mean sounding things right
everyone's friends here i need to start
playing quicker
can we play again um
no and now bishop f3 i don't know
i'll play you eventually though i just i
want to uh
play uh play blitz for now certainly
there is some compensation but probably
not enough
bishop takes on e3 no mega lil
exactly like i'm just being honest
i'm an honest guy not gonna sugarcoat it
anyways this position is really good
i win a pawn at some point i'm not sure
or at least just look at his look at his
dudes
what are they doing and i had against
like similar to this
not sure about that play rookie seven
introduce a slight wrinkle
of course rook d4
okay i'm kind of choking
this one looks like it's really oh i'm
not kind of joking about it
i feel like i should he's winning you're
doing better than i am
how do i attack his pawn i want to
attack his pawn in that position so
after that
i don't know what to do
i have to start making chess news or
something and i'm
at any rate one more game please i want
to sleep
oh update title yeah you're right i'll
uh i'll do that in a second
after this game
i'll play you one more game this
position which it looks like he should
not
it's gonna go there i don't want him to
go there so i'll play this
does that even stop it i don't think
that's something all right well he
didn't play it so i guess i stopped it
you might just be able to take and then
play rick d6 time pressure
no i mean i have like some attackers
i need to play quicker just
the computer preparation ugh playing so
slow
a6 was unnecessary i don't really
remember the position oh he attacked my
pawn i didn't notice
why didn't he tell me okay so i sacked
upon
let's find out why i sacked upon um
yes this is pretty bad i'm gonna flag it
as well
but okay maybe not he that was a bad
move for him
and now i'm definitely losing but
who knows if i'll lose that's a good
move
i'm just gonna go okay i think he should
have gone this way but and
maybe i can flag him here f4 then i'm
down on time he seems kind of slow rook
to e4
i'll just like run my king off the board
so what happens when you guys make him
play blitz hey i can
i can win in blitz
david no i i don't want to play three
plus one if you challenge me three plus
zero i'll play you right now
but i don't like increments this is
not going to be easy for him to survive
this position next game be classical
with two hour time control
it's a funny question very funny
question
by the way
uh i'm gonna update my title now
and now in this position the the regular
move
no surprise uh
can you turn off this annoying
commentary
i'll do a poll in a second
and
i'll do a poll right now see if you guys
like the commentary
i personally i can see why
um
i can see why you would like it or why
you wouldn't like it because
you know just opinion i guess
uh but i like it because without it it's
just really quiet
but it but he's been finding all
everyone vote in the poll
moves a computer suggestion pokemon go
to the polls
then turn on some music i don't know if
i'm able to turn on music
i think that might be uh
i think i'm not i'm told not to turn on
music i think
all right uh david usa two one one two
eight zero if you want to play me then
challenge me three plus o otherwise i
will just play another game
right now it's all about okay
right now it's four to five strategy
worked
check this out noah's winning
i hope that you guys don't think this
means um
my own commentary i'm pretty sure
everyone knows that means maurice right
okay no one four five to four but that's
not many people voted but it was a sharp
sharpening of the game with a
concrete threat wait a minute what's
going on even american voters voted
better than
than this uh than this poll
okay i'm david usa won't create a new
challenge so i'm just gonna play another
game
and i will turn off
there's nothing here
uh there's copyright free stuff i think
um i think i'm just not supposed to at
all
okay this guy's going real fast it's a
speedster
bishop d6 doesn't this win
[Music]
um knows
probably not because he has like this
check or something
let's let me calculate let me spend all
my time calculating it
i guess i'll just play this i really
want to
okay seems pretty good for me
bishop d2 or c4 was fine wasn't it
uh yeah that would i would not be in
check anymore but it wouldn't win a
piece
so yeah i don't know if that would have
been so good
okay this looks like a really good
position for me because i'm gonna play
this or something
and i can play this you can play this
could do everything
why are we still here
what does that mean i'm not sure
oh my god you leader mc just
pre-fired that message
okay so if i'm not winning this position
then i don't know what a
winning position means anymore
what's the best move probably this and
then this or something
about this move
rook would be trapped um but i don't i
can't like actually win the rook though
so it's probably not that good he can't
really move any of his pieces
which is kind of nice
i want like a killing blow but there's
not really anything
maybe i start with this move and then
after this
whoa what are you doing buddy
what are you doing
he's doing nothing oh i kind of i have
this move i didn't even notice
so i'll play it rook h7
i think his strategy is just to play the
most confusing move
that's legal
um
[Music]
how do i win let's start with this i
guess
good night for now good night
wow okay this is just this is so
lost come on
this is so lost
wow he took that he took it
okay so he's gonna play queen e6 i guess
it's his idea
i think even if i trade queens i'm
winning that's how winning this is
this might also win a rook who knows
let's find out
and iris says i'm playing bad chess come
on come on
queen a7 is is not the move of a bad
of a person playing chess badly right
look at this game look at this game look
at this position do you see his position
i've never seen a position this bad
i respect your moves thank you sir
all right iris all right i get it
i have a cool continuation if he takes i
take this
come on there's like there's got to be
some like mate or something
okay so i take this if he takes me i
have mate if he doesn't take me i just
play rookie seven
there might be something else but who i
don't need to find something else
um and somehow i wanna
i can just play queen c7 but that's kind
of lame
okay played that what if i play this
move
[Music]
oh my god this is such a nice mate look
at this he takes i
check check checkmate and if he moves
here i play rookie yeah
can we get some let me get some pog wait
pog champ exists right
does pog chip still exist
i don't know if pogchamp still exists
but can we get some emo that i don't
know i don't know what the replacement
is now it is
if pogchamp exists right i try
actually no i'm not going to try that
would be kind of like i'd be kind of um
it's a word it's the word when you're
self-centered
pogchamp there we go okay let's let's
just look at this game
this is a nice game
that's what i like to see narcissistic
yeah
okay so i don't think you can see the
evaluation one second
um look at this
let's just um okay so it's a little
shaky right i didn't play
the best moves let's see it's g3 when
i'm supposed to play or what
okay so just it's saying bishop e3 and
then like
just move black should move the bishop
away
that's kind of funny okay but i played
this all good
this was all good this was all good this
is all good
wants me to play 94 first which makes
sense but
i didn't think him playing bishop b7 was
so good i'll just trade and then play 94
after
okay 94. yeah so like literally what i
said i should do is what i should have
done
okay f5 is not the best move but it's a
good move
and he played rick h7 and then the rest
i played like a genius
even queen a7 is the best move
i took all his dudes brook d5's
okay bishop h6 come on bishop h6 is a
great move
i'm glad that i found this
i don't think i've ever played a move
this good my life
alright we go again
i'm like five minutes away from stl
chess club can we play there even if
we're trash
um yeah anyone is real welcome to play
and your first visit is free and
i'm not i haven't physically been to the
um i haven't physically been to the
chest live in a while because um
yeah i'm just a little i'm over i'm safe
about coated uh like i'm not working
there
so i'm just like a little cautious about
that i know that people work
or people work there people go there
right now i don't know about like the
attendance
um nowadays i think people still show up
i think there should be players players
for you
um
but yeah you're welcome to show up you
could also call them and ask if players
are there if you want to uh
make sure okay so
iris and i lift this line one one day i
think
maybe i don't know about this one this
one i probably would just dismiss and i
was like yeah okay white's just
white's way better yeah it's 811 right
now
who knows if b4 is right i probably
should review this
okay that's a free pawn i'm gonna play
b6 afterwards or something
hmm
i think he is i actually don't know if i
can take that pawn
shred rooks
black has to play a5 here
i don't believe that a5 is a good move
okay now i'll take this pawn finally
i don't think i'm afraid of queen a8
right
and i don't know okay i should have been
afraid of that i kind of missed that he
attacked my
pawn to be honest but this should still
be good for me i think
yeah we'll go here my rook here
maybe play h4 my guys uh
my guys are batteried up
should probably just go back but i don't
know how he
i guess he defends it like this maybe
don't forget the knight g5 stuff
yeah but um can't really do it here
i don't know what to do he's gonna play
this obviously oh what
not obviously i guess i think he should
have
this feels feels kind of bad right
did you go here
i really just didn't expect that
um
[Music]
this feels like a concession to go back
right
let's go here uh i need to make a move i
need to make a move
this is really bad i took way too long
on that move and i'm not even better
anymore probably
yeah not ideal not ideal
the crop is messed up oh you're right
i fixed it thanks for letting me know
okay he didn't like stop my threat
um he's gonna take my guy
so now we just play like this he has to
play this
and then who knows what's happening
after that
maybe i should
huh i'm also attacking this pawn but he
she should
he should defend that right
i hug the chat look at chat oh he played
that i didn't see that move
okay my queen invades right
why don't you play five plus zero when
you're kind of slow sometimes
i'm kind of slow primarily because i'm
reading chat i would say
normally i win my chess games by
flagging my opponents
in this game i might checkmate him
though
ooh i see it see a cool line
here here
if he takes with king i play bishop c5
and then check checkmate oh i didn't see
that
okay now i'm losing i think
um well okay maybe not
but i'm gonna flag it at least
i'm a little too i should have played
bishop c3
um yeah i should have played bishop c3
last move
here i'll try to flag him but i'm not
going to he played he should have played
queen f8
here i i don't even know if i'm losing
yeah i think i think he should have
played queen f8
here where was it in this position i
thought he'd play queen f8
because then because okay here
what he did allowed me to do this and
then if he takes my a piece i have
oh okay this didn't even work but this
is what i thought i thought this would
like checkmate him or something
but i thought he would play queen f8 and
then force me to trade
because if i move my bishop i'd lose
this piece
um rocket launchers is challenging me to
casual
3-0 blitz yeah can someone clip that can
someone clip that
that's pretty pretty good game at the
end like in the only at the very
end when it was a bullet time scramble
was when i played well
like obviously not well but i didn't
play what good
moves but
okay
quranka virus very cool name
i think the uh is it overly messed up
it's a little bit messed up
i'll fix this this should be better
it's nothing to him exactly
okay let's see if he takes this okay so
this is
jonathan trans is opening which i don't
know
okay i'm pretty sure i'm supposed to
take this he's supposed to play this
move
but he didn't and i'm supposed to play
this
and then someone who watched jonathan's
video probably knows the answer
of what i'm supposed to do here but
don't tell me because that's cheating
probably says to take this right do you
know what
when and why saint louis got the lm
title no
uh we're just cool
that's my answer okay isn't it like this
or something
is this the right position
is it bishop g5 knight g5
it's probably one of those right this
isn't the time to play bishop h6 i don't
think
i don't know this looks like good move
i'm thinking too long though that's a
problem
only i actually knew the openings that i
played
imagine imagine how good i would be
what's my threat i actually don't know
what my threat was last move
i don't okay this feels wrong now
because he plays he gets to play this
move
oh no but i have the track nevermind
yeah that's no this is fine this is fine
i think i'm winning
although like once we simplify and stuff
i don't really know how i win
okay that seems like a good move
i probably messed up i don't know maybe
i think knight g5 was just wrong then if
this doesn't work
might want to resign to be honest
okay i'm resigning i think probably
bishop bishop g5 was what i wanted to
play but i trusted the chat
wow okay you can't see the engine right
now but bishop g5 was the best move oh
you can see the line
and apparently i'm still losing it's
king f8
genius move
i guess you probably probably would have
seen this but this looks good for me
right
i would have yeah i would have played
that position i don't know you said it
so confidently
okay this is opening
i feel like i play this opening in half
of my chess games that's blah
i'll play b3 soon
i need to play faster so i can flag my
opponents because i'm not playing chess
very well right now
well i'm playing okay i just i keep
getting losing positions and then
flagging my opponents which is how it
normally goes i guess
should i take it with this guy eric why
are you ignoring the challenge
of a two-time minecraft world record
holder okay
you say minecraft world record holder
it's very suspicious
um i think you should include the
category in which you achieved a world
record in
i think it's kind of important
i do respect you obviously your
accomplishments
should have taken with the night i don't
like this at all
i don't know what to do
they call me minecraft carlson i don't
think anyone calls you that
but if you call yourself that that's
cool
need to make a move i need to make a
move
when are you gonna play puzzle racer um
[Music]
i don't know a couple couple blitz wins
i think
i don't know i'm definitely able to get
this rating higher so i kind of want to
try
i mean wait
what are you asking jamaica feeling
uh okay so he's threatening this so i
probably need to stop it
which way do i go
i guess i'll go this way and then knight
f8 is never made
that's my plan i missed that
does this work
this doesn't work but this is like a
decent position i think if i try this
because he takes me i go there we go
i missed that i missed the free queen
please no one ever watch me again
uh can i puzzle erase you after this
game i forgot my king was on
h8 i thought it was on g8 that's why i
missed that
uh dude i gotta go do my 40 hours of
practice soon
i don't know what that's referring to oh
never mind
i guess i know what that's referring to
but sure i'll play you in puzzle
race i guess
um do you have a private account as well
or just playing on san diego
i have a private account i guess but i
don't
it's kind of a secret you know
uh and i don't play like that much
i play sometimes usually my
yeah never mind i don't need to go into
it but i play sometimes on another
account i won't say my name though
no i don't want to give the name of my
account i guess i can give you one name
my one account that i own that i used to
play on which i kind of
uh you can go to blindfold billy that's
this is uh
this is the account that everyone knows
me by
i don't know how to show it on the
screen um that weird cropping but
oh yeah the the uh the green screen
thing looks kind of weird on this
but
but yeah i'm what 2500
oh i want to play ultra bullet on the
san luis chess club account
also because um
ultra bullet rating is really low
no i don't use iris's account okay i'm
going to send a puzzle eraser challenge
i think this link should work right let
me make sure that it's
it shows on the screen yeah i need to um
i need to fix this
let's go duplicate boom
give me a second to set this up i'll do
it
live
also
okay what i'm gonna do
is move this
does it show the timer i think it shows
the timer like up here or something
so i have to make this smaller
i think this might work
oh wait i know what to do the timer is
going to show up down here
um try joining this link
if you want to play me in puzzle eraser
10. click that link
nine oh eight gotta go fast it starts in
ten seconds apparently five
four three two i'm going to be spending
some time setting this up first
and then i'll just start late i guess
okay and then
the timer is right here
i think that's about it oh there's a
little combo thing at the bottom
i wish this wasn't so long
okay
cool everyone's so far ahead
oh i wanna i can't show the uh
the race thing at the bottom i guess
yeah i'm just gonna
surrender this uh this run and i'll
start on the next one
because obviously i was uh messing
around
we had to do another window capture for
the score and put it where the clock was
i think this works i think i uh i got
the um
the layout correctly
i just wish i could show the race thing
but
it might be just impossible to be honest
we need to see the race hmm
problem is my window like you physically
cannot see
you can't see it you just can't i can't
i can't even see it myself
all right everyone join the rematch
can you share the whole screen i can but
i no like i said i can't see the
race part of my screen six five
four three here's the link two all right
i'm gonna focus
zero i'm gonna do so well everyone's
gonna be so amazed
ah my mouse can't reach that far it's
not fair
how does it work when you get one wrong
what's the punishment because i don't i
don't really know
um this is a win
okay yeah of course of course
obviously keep miss clicking that's kind
of annoying
i'm not miss clicking but like i pick up
the piece on the wrong square a lot
so i should be winning a queen somehow
maybe not
i'm in check oh i would be in check if i
did that
don't bother oh not only this ones
um
check checkmate
oh it's over i got 82. hey i won
i won i won by quite a bit you can't see
the bottom
shoot you can't see the bottom this
ruins it all i need to uh
i need to add a a way to see this at the
end
you can't see all the people which is
which kind of ruins the point but um
you know i think i know how i can do
this
well maybe not i had 82 and the next
person had 47.
oh no i had to wait i'm not gonna wait
starting a new one alright
if you would like to play me in puzzle
race and join this
i'm gonna get 90. if anyone can beat me
in this
i will nine eight seven
i don't know hey you're good at chess or
something
three two i can't give subs i won't give
subs
but i will say you're good at chess
which is a very oh no i messed up
my first mistake how much what do i lose
for that i don't know
uh i should be winning yeah it's a free
queen
there should be some winning yeah
uh this wins a pawn i feel like there
should have some
okay we win a queen somehow
this one's a brook this one's a queen
this mates this mates
this one's queen it's mates
uh this should win something right
i misclicked oh my god i
i clicked on the right i knew what the
move was
is it me or not really but
uh this is a free piece
should be something here this is me
this should be
uh this should win a piece somehow right
like this this should mate
probably right maybe not
this one's okay i still
won but i kind of want to know the
answer to this
oh wait what i don't know what is this
sorry to see the answer
i don't know
your voice distracts me nine eight
smooth the stream six five
four three two one
oh so i think getting more in a row
gives you
combo so when i mess up uh when i mess
up one i don't like lose time or
anything but
i miss out on points
what was that that should've been easy
oh what's happening that's a big
movement on the board
uh
ah move move i miss clicking so much
uh it was riptix then i guess that's
annoying
uh this is a big joke very big choke
i missed that for so long as well miss
that
oh no it's all collapsing
so queen should win somehow
this has to win right it doesn't win
maybe there's something with
bishop f2
i have no clue okay this is a check i
just found out
dude that's this is really bad i'm gonna
lose
did i win i still won that was terrible
oh my god is 76 your actual puzzle storm
record
um no i think it's i think 77 but i'm
pretty sure
in in puzzle storm you don't get bonus
points so like i didn't
solve 65 puzzles so it's not um
the point system isn't equivalent really
ten nine okay i'm gonna do like seven
a couple more of these try to try to get
an idea
three lists two one
zero i'm playing pretty badly right now
uh what's going on
oh my queen is on c7 jesus
um does that
is this when i'm so confused right now
it should be easy i don't i don't
understand that one so i'm just gonna
skip
i need i wish i could see the answers
afterwards but i don't know how to
this is bad this is bad what is the move
here
what is going on there isn't a good move
that was that was it that was the answer
i don't understand that
okay i gotta go faster faster faster
faster faster faster faster faster
that should have that win that one let's
let's be honest with ourselves
let me have one
um
55 i still won
um knight g3 queen g2 bra
where was my knight in that position
because i remember i had a bishop on f1
and a king on eric and a queen on
h3 right i don't remember the position
and i don't know how to uh go back
the enemy knight was protecting me yeah
i remember that
there was so many there were a lot of
deflections i was looking at none of
them worked
um okay i'm done i'm done with that
now that all the haters are gone i can
play bullet again
oh we played queen ticks
oh i didn't mean to play one minute this
is way too slow
the board is screwed my bad i'll fix it
should work now
um
anticipating this
am i a hater
no only a mild hater i have much bigger
hitters
okay this looks very bad i think i'm
winning a piece
okay i'm winning a piece that's right
but my pieces are not so developed yeah
i just need to consolidate he can take
this which i missed but
it's still really good now defending
everything
uh i can just win his pawn probably
so i'll do that
i miss this of course that's the only
threat with this move
but i'm still probably winning right
takes that i need to move
i need to move
he should have played that this should
be winning
again
i didn't mean to pre-move that okay what
if i win anyways though
that'd be crazy
winnable this is so winnable okay i did
ah i messed up again
now i've lost for sure why do you play
so much worse on stream
why are you so mean on stream
okay i'll actually win now i'll actually
win now i was just kidding that game
okay actually for real getting to 2300
in the next
10 minutes
well actually that might be impossible
but i'll win all my games
thanks josh
no losses no losses
a single loss is about to happen you're
gonna you're about to witness history
biggest win streak on leachat
wow he hung it
i'm not mean i'm always like this so
you're always mean
sorry hate watchers weird champ
yes people who watch that are haters
thanks for the viewers
no iris it's not allowed also what do
you mean
i'm literally do you want to play you
want to play me
on that account what are you like 2400
something
i'd rather just play like random people
this is bad i don't know what i'm doing
i also missed
that this is free attack on titan poster
in the background nice
thank you i hope
you don't question me about attack on
titan
because i know nothing about it
all right goodbye iris i will be 2400
when you come back
if i'm not 2400 when you're back i i
consider that a failure
don't worry i know i'm hanging on my
pieces but he's hanging them even more
wait you don't watch so the story behind
the poster
is i watched the first season and and i
loved it
and i never watched again like during
the time when i loved it i bought the
poster
and i wanted the reason i bought the
poster was not just because i liked the
show but because
i wanted to be this is very strange
saying it out loud but i wanted to be
relatable to
weebs uh because a lot of my friends
like anime
so i wanted to be cool because weebs are
cool
they're taking this
i missed this somehow that was like the
only thing for him to do
ugh i'm bad i'm bad this guy's this
guy's a little bit
weird uh with his speed so i need to
probably pay more attention
he just speeds up at random moments
that's how he's winning
i mean he's playing pretty badly
i i didn't realize he played rick d8
okay he missed him in one
let's just simplify this didn't really
simplify as many things harder and my
computer's lagging
it also makes things harder
okay i had to pay attention i guess this
guy's just a little bit too fast
i haven't watched season four
yeah i don't i don't know what's going
on in that show i know it's it's really
popular now like when i watched it
obviously it was popular because attack
on titan but
it's definitely grown a lot somehow i
guess the new stuff is really good
i just shouldn't have sacrificed this
probably
just a little bit ambitious of me
and now i'm just lost okay well now i'm
not just lost because you gave me this
pawn
[Music]
now you can't get back
and i'll meet him i only watched naruto
but i loved it
i i've well through i've been through
multiple phases where i wanted to watch
certain animes but i never did
i found a piece it's fine
uh but yeah i mean i might
one day i'm eating him
really close
uh what if i do like this
that should made him right
fine i'll just go like this
[Music]
oh he's defending that it's fine
anime manga in general have gained a lot
of popularity in the past couple years
yeah it's kind of weird not like not you
know
it's debatable whether the thing itself
is weird obviously i'm not
talking about that i don't really
understand why it's more popular now
because like personally i've known oh
[ __ ] that was miss click oh shoot
um personally i've known about it about
both of those for a while obviously
uh
so i don't know why they've randomly
blown up
oh yeah that's gonna hurt that's gonna
hurt
[Music]
it's just gonna hurt when i don't win
this game
should have taken that
i was watching um what's it called
what is even is it what even is it
called i don't know what i was watching
i know what it was about about like this
orphanage
um these orphanage people
is like it's an anime about an orphanage
come on someone someone's gotta know it
right and it's like
the the people who own the orphanage are
kind of like murderers basically
the promise neverland yeah i live i can
remember the name of the show that shows
you how
how dedicated i am to anime um
but yeah i watched i started watching
that i watched like four episodes in a
day and then i just didn't watch it
again because that's
that's just how i roll
i miss this of course
yeah i this guy he's fast he's so bad
but he's fast
it's sort of working against me
i'm watching so much right now that's
why i didn't even want to start it yet
yeah that's a problem that i have um
with with anime is like they're so long
right
that if i start one i'm just basically
committing like my life to
finishing it kind of because i when i
start things i want to finish
them that's just kind of how i work so
i know if i start an anime then my life
is basically just
it's like dedicated to that okay i
should have taken all this stuff
so that's why i don't really watch anime
it's one of the reasons
also i'm really bad at chess right now
really really bad
you just just play better
is he gonna find mate he did
i need to look at the chessboard instead
of talking about anime
i thought i took with the rook
that's obviously not what i'm about to
do
i don't know why he's not checking me
there oh
this is work there's queen c2 i guess
yeah i need to
play better
queen g3 good move
people are always telling me to start
one piece if i'm not about to start a
show with the 900 shows and still
counting
yeah exactly it's
kind of just a lot of time commitment
oh um i'm playing really bad
but he's trying to play worse than me
which is nice i guess
what's your bullet rating oh ultra
baller rating
um i don't know i think like
2100 or something but it's very very
uh what's the word volatile
ultra bullet is is obviously the um the
least
like consistent rating that you can have
being
being
2100 ultra bullet could mean i'm like
1900 ultrabook the next day
okay this looks like a good position for
me
oh he attacked it i didn't realize
that's just sad she said
yeah i'm playing super bad sorry about
that
everyone
very very bad chess
yeah i need to play one minute
so i'm trying to not actively speaking
during
all the game but it's just difficult to
um
to play that type of player i was
playing when i had to
talk a little bit at least attempt to
talk a little bit
you got 2100 ultra bullet while i'm
struggling to make break 1900 rapid
well those aren't really the same like
being 2100 ultra bullet doesn't mean
that i'm uh
good at rapid necessarily or anything
like that
you're gonna go to bed all right goodbye
jamaica feeling thanks for
thanks for being here
does this work kind of feels like it
might work so i'm gonna do it
oh no no no i meant to put i meant to
play this first
okay maybe this maybe this is fine who
knows
probably not losing a piece at least
just all i care about
okay well this is obviously uh
could not have asked for much better
than this i guess
go win his pawn now
okay give me a rook i'll take that
and then we make a queen then we made
them
we'll get to at least 2300 today
and bullet
wow probably should play knight f6
the worst part about bullet is winning a
winning position
because you're just like why won't he
just resign
sometimes you lose those games
like this game i could very easily lose
this is not a good move
i'm a little bit up on time but
nothing crazy i need to like win his
pawns
i'll just click here actually go here
okay all right one now
[Music]
okay we're on the climb
65 points is kind of a lot though
do you know karen karen who
i blundered
wow what he could have just taken it
um i don't even know what to take it
right now
oh my god i missed this why am i trying
to be fancy
oh this is so bad
uh yeah karen who i know many karen's
like i've heard
the name karen that's what you're asking
but i assume that's not what you're
asking
okay let's just take every pawn why not
ah how dare he do that
that's not allowed
you should go there yeah did go there
um i guess i'll run my king over here
yeah i'm just i'm gonna flag i'm gonna
get mated
everything's gonna i could lose this
game in any way
maybe not though it'd win
now i'm gonna win
okay i want to simplify it doesn't even
care
let's make a queen these positions
aren't actually that easy to win
it's kind of hard to make him i'll just
make a bunch of legal moves and
hopefully i mess up
okay let's just not stalemate him
hopefully
uh karen feingold
i know karen feingold i know
i know her existence
i've met her before at the saint louis
chess club that i was like
a child so i doubt she remembers me
uh so yeah
you are good thank you i hope i am
decent
sometimes i play good but usually not
are you oh i missed this are you new to
the stlcc
uh no i've
i've been working here since august 2019
but
as a streamer i am new
streamer today is my first stream and
i've been going to the chess club for a
long time since 2011
and i'm currently 17 although my
birthday is tomorrow
so i've been that's pretty long time you
know
this probably makes him that'd be cool
if he does this i missed that he had
yeah he had that but this is nice he had
a queen takes e7 and i wouldn't be
winning
oh no i missed rook f6
tried to be fancy okay but this is this
is obviously still winning
and if we're good fate okay well he just
allowed maiden one
i think you should have played rook f8
though
okay we'll adopt this guy i don't think
you guys can see the score
right now i'll i'll try to fix that but
i'm winning four to zero
oh that was bad i should have played
queen c7 first
still so solid uh
not sure what that's referring to
hopefully my chess
um i don't know what i did that game
that was solid but i'll take it thank
you
any compliments about my chests are
appreciated always
i miss this move less last turn but
this might have even been better
honestly
okay we take all of his pieces
i had one legal move there so i played
it
i think i might start taking opening
requests getting bored of
deciding on my own
yes pure chess as karen
huh
does karen go to chess i haven't really
kept up with her her game is in a while
i missed that somehow
never play f6
yeah this is a problem this is a big
problem
okay that's a small problem
let's do here
um i have no idea what to do i guess i
attack that or something
yes it's not so good
okay wait he's giving me a chance
yeah he's giving me a big chance okay
what
should have taken midnight probably but
um this might win
that doesn't work i'll just take
that's bad this is all bad hang your yes
thank you not sure if i could have done
that without him
okay and now we go take this pawn and
then we promote we'll make two queens
just for fun
jerome gambit yeah i can do that
actually wait what is the drone gambit
isn't that like queen h5 it's like um
this and then this i think that's
something else
because if that's what it is then i
don't think i can i don't know if i can
beat this guy with that
we'd have to that we'd have to get
pretty lucky to
beat at 20 what is this guy 2100 that
opening
i'm not sure if i'm at that level
okay he's just not castling for some
reason which is very weird
it's very very weird does this win
i take all of his rooks and then i'm up
yeah okay
we're at seven to zero
we're swinging what
you can check me but i go there and i
take the dude
i'll look at that notation in a second
pretty queen
oh it's bishop f7
right okay i can i don't know if i
should try that
i'm trying to maybe i would try it
against like
a viewer who's bad someday not bad
you know lower rated my bad
i just don't think it'll uh have too
much success
at this current level
this guy's just hanging all of his
pieces very generous
oh i meant to play ricky one first or
eight whatever
should still win now obviously
when you have more books than your
opponent that's usually good
okay it took me a second to realize how
to trade queens
okay we're just going to pick up the
pawns
then try to trade rooks that'd be
promoter queen
all right nine zero after i adopt this
guy i'll play another
person
this is not good
yeah i kind of provoked e6 i think you
should play b5 here
hanging upon but who cares
look how much time i'm gaining
can i ask permission oh you're
sending a link to chess bros channel
i think everyone knows
[Music]
uh everyone knows chess broadway very
cool
channel of course this is a cool move i
think
i should have played rook a3 actually
instead
okay um
we're at what are we at 22.67
oh how can i ask permission sorry i
misread that
i can permit you but also i don't really
want you to send up links
anyways
all right um
yeah we're just gonna keep keep playing
that was that one minute
that was 30 second right i want a
slightly higher rated opponent to farm
like i was kind of getting low
is
someone play me please
all right
i think you might have typed a i in your
stack
so oh my
need to have
i don't know what that means
i have no clue what that means
i should be winning oh but no he can
just take probably
i think he could have taken
[Music]
oh my god i thought he thought he played
something else i'm down a queen
don't worry i win these i win these
i win these obviously obviously
i should have played the h7 oops
[Music]
uh maybe eric is the best at the moment
what do you
what are you talking about i'm always
the best
oh yeah adiche
i don't really like what i'm doing
i wondered he didn't take it
still a blunder to be honest
he can we can win this
that's a man yeah i can't win this this
guy is bad because
uh it's beatable speedable it's getting
lucky
are we focused now focus big focus hours
i'll remove every move in the opening
look how scared he is
i want him to tremble with fear
uh crumble inferior that's how it goes
right
just relax i'm fine i mean
just gotta get lucky sometimes i missed
this move last night
the general trend is obviously up so
anyway anytime i lose this it's fine
uh what's going on why did i play that
move yes
i need to start studying again i've been
addicted to it
to mtg which is magic the guardian
magic what's called magic the gathering
magic the gathering
wow cannot speak that's cool
i used to play that game a while ago
i spent actually like a lot of money on
cards in that game
i guess my problem with card games is
just like
it's very hard to not make them pay to
win in my eyes
because it's like you need you need the
best cards to win right
that seems strange i shouldn't have
played this but maybe it's just a good
sacrifice who knows
i'm attacking that and i didn't take it
sure why
now i can just go like this and i think
i messed up
well now i didn't miss it this looks
good this looks very good
his dark squares are trash
i'm i'm not playing this well but i'm
gonna flag him anyways
i should have just played quinoa
successful okay i'm just gonna like flag
him
just to be funny
yeah that's what's good about rn mtg
arena it's completely free to play
well i don't think that makes it good
just because it's free to play because
like hearthstone's free to play too
right
um but it's still pay to win
right it's it's not completely pay to
win
i will admit there are obviously
elements of skill
involved but to me the fact that there's
like a barrier to entry
which is that you need to just have
certain cards
is a problem but i can once you get past
that
i think card games are cool
i don't think i'm playing this good yeah
that's a free queen for him
i clutched it did i clutch it this might
actually his queen's trapped as well
wow getting fancy but it doesn't work
okay he should have taken my rook i
don't know why he didn't
now all of the pieces are disappearing
are you looking for rapido games i mean
of course
the basics then rock solid
i'm not sure what you're saying or not
be honest you're talking to me
then no rapid games are too slow
this should work right who knows i mean
this this looks
looks like it wins somehow
somehow someway i should be winning this
position
i trust i guess he can take this
i think he should have taken that maybe
okay but now he can't defend the knight
enough
i miss that oh wait i didn't miss his
queen saying
[Music]
he had me thinking i messed up not gonna
lie
mtg arena makes every legal card
obtainable for free
um that's good but
i need to learn i need to know more
about it because you're being a little
bit big i know you're not like
you're probably not sponsored by mtg or
anything so
you're not like a spokesperson but yeah
i would need to look up more because
just because every card's obtainable for
free doesn't
mean that it's like not easier when you
pay
this position is kind of trash you
should check me
for that you should still check me now
you should still check me now okay now
i'm fine thank
what bishop's on the same diagonal buddy
i was going crazy
oh he resigned i thought i got flagged
good debut stream will be a new regular
good night
goodbye banana thank you for coming
i hope to see you again
wow f6 i should have just taken it i
kind of just
that move shocked me so much now
we almost have may not quite
okay 22.82 the only thing that costs
real money are card packs but you can
get them for free too
i mean again how long does it take on
to get the free cards with card packs
right
because everything you're saying just
reminds me of hearthstone
um i'm sure they're different games but
the um
the attaining cards element sounds
similar and
okay i just need 18 more points to get
to 2300.
if anyone's good at bullet
challenge me
oh cool i know this guy
not playing good
i miss this
huh just like this
one pack is 1k gold you can get 1k
gold every day
i would assume if it's that easy then
probably one pack doesn't
give you a lot
okay you not rated
what does that mean
oh
okay luckily this guy's slow
i missed 92 didn't play it though
i'm blundering everything
[Music]
just check them
ah that's good move
hi what is that oh that's mine
i just gotta play better a little bit
simply better
okay this position is good just put my
knight
okay attacking his pawn
defended his pawn let's go this let's
put my queen on this diagonal
oh that's i miss this
should still be good though this is free
pawn this is going to be a free pawn
i think he can take my exchange but
i'm attacking the knight he can't even
go anywhere
that's a reasonable move we'll just
trade
i'll win the piece now i have more time
and i'm not material
i miss that but it's fine
he's losing all his pieces and i'm going
to flag here some slow
then i'll check him a bunch i'll make a
queen and he'll do nothing
yeah and when you first start you get
five decks and then a few decks later i
think they give you 15 free decks for
your first week of flying
sounds cool probably not going to try it
but
sounds like a cool game like i know a
lot of people who are into that game
ah that's miss book
okay big deflection
oh i really want a sack but it doesn't
work
huh you play this
you have to suck
[Music]
yeah and this is not good obviously but
you make it work
i don't know why you sack there now
we'll just check them a bunch and see
maybe something good will happen
i missed clicked many times there yeah
how did how do you have so much time
what when did that happen
i'm gonna have to pre-move more
i really hate this guy's opening i hate
i don't know what to do against today
it's just very basic very very basic
stuff
i should know just like uh whatever that
setup is called
just does it every it's really annoying
to play against because it's like
it feels like i should just be winning
winning so quick
i'm not
it's a free piece i don't know why i'm
doing it like this
okay this is an easy one if i might
break back on this side and then do this
you should play this now yeah i just
take all the pawns
i miss that you could take that with
chuck but
we're just going to hide over here i'm
going to make a move that only wins a
few
moves okay i should have just attacked
this pawn but i misclicked
now we're winning i flag
ah okay we had to play faster
and that's a premium a lot i want to
beat this guy like
cleanly i wasn't miss clicking let's
play f4 which is
very not close to where i ended up going
he just doesn't lose time as quickly as
i feel like
just slightly annoying
it's my work yes
i'm sure i scared him with all my
pre-moves
[Music]
all right cool
yo stl keep eric on he's entertaining
thank you thank you keen wealthy peach
oh okay
i shouldn't have taken that probably
facts ah
thank you guys
you missed that
oh i'm not playing this well ooh that's
cool i didn't see he could do this
now i'm losing oh that was a freak queen
i didn't even notice
i didn't i didn't mean to castle here i
didn't realize it was legal like i had
to make a premium
trick i worked
but yeah i'm just losing very badly
i can't believe i choked this one
he hung his queen
he sacked his queen
is there a flag yeah of course
look at his time wait look at his time
it's like
it's going down and then going up that's
why it's felt so weird
oh i'm not crazy for once
okay this is just an easy one if i lose
this that's a miracle honestly
um
i'm gonna lose this gotta lose it
it's gonna happen i blundered a piece
okay he didn't see it
i'm gonna flag and a flag and
hang all my stuff not a good combination
not a good combination
not even threatening anything yeah
i'm going to take this i'm going to lose
all my pieces
it's going to check me i'm worried
though
i can flag him
he keeps not pre-moving at times where i
think he's gonna pre-move because he
it's really hard to tell what moves her
pre-moves by him because he's not losing
any time no matter what
yeah i know i can't play this guy i
can't play this guy it's just really
frustrating actually
i need someone who like has an internet
connection
okay 24.55
this is this is like where i would say
my ratings should be hopefully
or above this
um so hopefully this will be a good
match
okay it's a good match it's close
i almost lost there
okay another guy reading
uh this guy's opening is terrible
ready mate i found it
this is just completely winning it might
work to take that but
it's kind of unnecessary oh
that's a very bad mouse slip in that
position
okay i'm losing peace the number one
thing in bullet when you lose a piece is
you
keep playing moves because as soon as
you're like
wow i should not have done that or
whatever
and you start to think and you start to
lose time
i don't want to lose some time for sure
yeah he's fast
it's not playing amazingly definitely
very beatable
[Music]
i can't move
yeah that was that was really bad i
missed my king
like three seconds
this is a really weird position
[Music]
um making a queen
vanessa a nice
doesn't want to play me again
this guy wants to play me though but
he's only 2171 how am i supposed to
farm
uh i don't like any position i
thought he i don't know what i thought
i don't have an excuse that was terrible
okay we win this
have i ever lost this no
look at this god winning i am
i'm not actually threatening a mate yet
very close to threatening me
i'm gonna allow him to sack which is
definitely good for him but
okay he doesn't do it just very peculiar
because i'm just playing now hey eric
are you winning
yes very winning
oh my god i just saw a
big explosion in the chat is it like
timeout stuff he's even more
entertaining at twitch.tv
tv yes i am
just kidding just kidding i'm not i
don't stream i rarely stream but if you
want to follow me then that's my twitch
okay this is some theory
i feel like you're supposed to play
knight there but who knows
apparently you just can't send links in
any version you just can't even
try how dare you try
don't worry they got the link they
already they're hooked up
okay i'm winning like every piece
moderator i'm begging you
i i mean no harm
it's the auto mod that's uh that's
deleting your messages
let's just just try this one
okay this is already looking good for me
huh i guess that's
reasonable
i'm just going to hide i really want to
sack here somehow
like here does this work let's find out
it takes that it's weird
um if he takes this i play h3
you aren't 2400 yet smh
the whole gang's here exactly oh we got
a subscriber
i don't have noises on for subscribers i
don't know if they like care if i add
that or not but thank you for the
subscriber
that's a bad move he's like
he's kind of delayed it's like making a
move reacting to what i played last move
sort of
my honest question is how much does this
help out regular chess
well let me give you an anecdote
from my life uh i am well okay i don't
know if i'm
considered state chess champion anymore
because there was no tournament
past couple years but in this
in uh two years ago i won state
championship right
my only preparation for that was playing
bullet
and um
playing atomic chess and i won and like
i'm like in the best
trust form of my life basically maybe
not right now but i was at least
um so yeah take that how you will
i believe i personally am a firm
believer that
bullet chest helps my chest because my
my classical rating also went up a lot
uh ever since i stopped getting lessons
and
started playing a lot of bullet so
i don't know could just be could just be
random
the the numbers don't lie
he mated magnus carlsen in three moves
after 100 bullet games that is not true
it's just not he said true fact but it's
just not true
i blundered
but okay i have like checks and stuff
i was there you're not there it just
didn't happen that'd be cool if it
happened but it didn't happen
it's not taking my pawn for some reason
take me please i'm giving you all my
pieces
just please take one of them they're
free
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna keep playing
i'm gonna
try to tempo this guy
even though i'm 2300 now okay he's
tilted
i think he's tilted
that was a bad move just testing his
tool
i think i'm good at making moves that do
nothing but win time
he was the chessboard
i think that would be like an art thing
where like i think i've seen that before
actually where a human
is a chess board like they lay on the
ground and they like play chess on it
that'd be cool if you're down to do that
um
make it happen i don't know what i'm
doing here
i'll find a way to win
his opening is really bad but somehow
i'm not like
breaking through at all i don't really
know why
i don't want to trade but i must i think
uh let's just like move my pieces around
maybe go here i miss that
uh okay my flag i'm just
i'm playing badly now but
uh probably flagging that i missed
yikes just
messed up a lot there um
what if they promoted the sink field cup
by playing real life
chess game with actors as the pieces
that would be very cool that's a great
idea
leader emcee hey eric
remember we spent a whole chess club
playing a blindfolded game like two
years ago yeah i do
that's really not worth my time at all i
think i needed to be somewhere actually
uh i probably still made it to the place
i needed to go
but at what cost
are you titled um i'm not titled
i'm simply a 2000
a measly 2000.
is there a way to send you a challenge
i can donate my title if you want it
no that's not how it works
we can we can contact vita if you want
if you're really uh
insistent on giving me it like i'd be
down to
to try
uh you want to send me a challenge
um there is a way to send me a challenge
but i think right now i'm just gonna
keep playing
uh bullet
against randoms just uh i'm i'm feeling
feeling good i'm getting a lot of points
so i think i'll just continue the
streaks
you should sell your title on on ebay
wcm title barely used
like new oh god
yeah that's a good knife that's a sock
oh no i made it
dang
uh i don't want to play this guy again
after losing it uh
it's a one that hurts that's a pretty
sad game
not really sure what happened there oh
okay i'm getting challenges
oh okay if your rating is is this then
yeah i'll play you
i think that's the guy you asked right
oh this was the guy who asked if i was
titled
um i'll play the highest rated dude
and i see arjun challenged me as well so
i might play him
okay i don't want to lose to viewers so
i'm going to like pay slightly more
attention i guess
so i wouldn't want to embarrass myself
i'm already embarrassing myself because
i'm losing
but maybe no one will know i'm losing
i'm only losing because i said i'm
losing
huh
okay well now i'm not losing i'll play
uh i'll play like
i don't know two two to four games
against you and arjun
just depending how uh how badly i play
which isn't too badly yet
i almost wanted that but i didn't
i'm not threatening mate but he thought
i was threatening me that's more
important
the idea of the threat is more important
than threat
okay well this that was a mistake by him
um huh what's going on
this i guess
i guess played this who knows i'm
definitely losing but
i'm gonna win on time somehow
that's a good move he's he's defending
well i think very well
and i got mated i made it i lost i lost
the game i said i was
gonna flag him in
okay i gotta pay more attention
no more losing to this guy playing a
match with them
i've decided
let's just take i gotta do it at some
point you know
i could have taken that could have also
taken this other rook
i took neither of his rooks
okay now i check my time
feed a is sketch uh
there's sketch because they caught yeah
the fact that you have to pay money for
titles is definitely strange to me
because it's like they're rewarding you
know good players right
but if the player is good at chess but
like not rich or something then
they're kind of just screwing them over
i feel like
it's a little weird to me
kind of cramped here so i'll just trade
oh i thought he
thought he played something else okay i
don't think i could flag him here
[Music]
again
very bad me not
my opponent i mean both of us played
badly i think we can agree on that
that's really messed up yeah
oh whoops it is kind of weird
because you know like imagine a person
like as strong as a grandmaster
and then he just can't become a
grandmaster because they just don't have
money
like it's very i just don't get it
obviously they need to make money
somehow i guess but don't they
don't they like hold tournaments and
things like that
if it's for gm the national federation
pays for it but why don't they pay for
everything
why why do they uh oh my god that's a
misclick
it's actually a good misclick though
meant to do the other thing
yeah but so why do they not care about
non-gms
kind of weird right
if i was if i was like becoming an im
and then
my federation all my friends are gm's my
federation won't pay for my im and i
would feel kind of bad
yeah not playing this well
he can just take it i think because he
has bishop c5 in the end
he who doesn't want to
[Music]
oh i hung my queen okay you didn't take
my queen
i like it when that happens
all right now it's game time
that's unfortunate
i should have taken that ah bishop d5
just play the move
how much does it cost i don't know ask
ask a violet flower
okay no more losses i said no we're lost
as another game but then i lost
i was i lied i'm sorry i'm not a liar i
swear
i just missed this okay doesn't take it
though
don't like what i'm doing at all
okay now i'm fine probably
why did i do it like that
okay yes this obviously but i might
maybe i can flag him here
definitely a flaggable position
yeah a4 tricked him because he was he
probably pre-moved queen takes a five
thousand those kind of games are really
hard to win
sometimes when uh like what in his
scenario where
you have like no time and you have to
you have to expect that premium like
it's very difficult
very very difficult
you should run for feed a president
not sure why you think i should run for
pday president
i'm quite under qualified
i'd say
i remember who the i feel like i know
some of the pda presidents
the old ones and i think they're
slightly more qualified than me
only slightly maybe yeah maybe i could
catch up
ah okay
it's not what i meant to do
he can't play knight f4 i was about to
have responded this move with this
i was about to respond to this move with
rick c1 which would have been bad after
that
yeah not not great not great oh
it's already 955.
all right well i'm gonna accept arjun's
challenge he's still here
oh he is still here instant response
all right i'm gonna play arjun until 10
o'clock and then i will leave
i already blundered
i have no idea how to play the french
hopefully i'm doing a good job so far
well already losing probably
huh
it's pretty fast i don't think arjun was
good at bullet
okay
nice unironically rex sink field could
probably become president
um i don't really think that it's just
like whoever has
more chess involvement becomes president
like i think there's other
aspects to it
i would assume maybe if he could i don't
know
i don't really know what it takes to
become a few day president it's a good
question
okay i'm blundering every move but
either one of us are seeing it so
is it really a blunder if no one sees
the bullet predicaments
okay whatever the offers the most
money okay iris no one was no one wants
to solve your math problems here this is
this is chess only
why are you doing math
who does math mathematicians
not be me
don't really know what i'm doing
definitely not playing good moves
can i take okay
[Music]
should be winning i think
oh no i meant to i should have played g5
well not running anyways okay ah i
flagged i thought i had two seconds left
oh my god i lost what did i lose
that's sad
all right i gotta go after this game i
suppose
okay a lot of pawns moving out the board
i blundered
that was not what i meant to do but okay
he fell for the trick that
shouldn't have been forced
all right
go hang out with nemo and chesweeb
good games arjun you're better at bullet
than i expected you to be
i thought it sounds mean but you're good
at bullet you're a good bullet
um
all right uh whoever's on the stl chess
club account
are you gonna raid someone should i raid
someone how does this uh how does it go
slash raid aka nemsko all right
i'm sure these 30 viewers will be
greatly
appreciated for her so yeah everyone
thanks everyone for watching if you
haven't if you are don't already know me
i'm going to be streaming again on
friday at 8pm i believe
so come check me out again goodbye
everyone
thank you